تم نصح الجمهور مرارًا وتكرارًا
باستخدام الماء والصابون لغسل
أيدينا بدلاً من الاعتماد على
معقم اليدين لذلك كنت أتساءل لماذا لا نستخدم
الصابون والماء لتطهير
الأسطح المنزلية مثل أسطح المطبخ
والتعبئة بدلاً من الاعتماد على
تطهير المناديل والبخاخات ، شكرًا
لأخذ سؤالي ،
سانجاي ، نعم رنا ، هذا
ربما يكون أحد أكثر الأسئلة شيوعًا لدينا
والإجابة هي نعم ، أعني
أنه يمكنك استخدام الصابون والماء بنفس
الطريقة التي قد تستخدم بها بعض
المنظفات المنزلية الأخرى ،
نحن نعرف ذلك من أجل
يديك ولكن بالنسبة لأجزاء أخرى من
منزلك أيضًا ، يمكن أن
تؤدي المهمة بالفعل هذا الأسبوع ، سألنا عما إذا كان بإمكانك
إظهار فعالية التنظيف
بالماء والصابون ، دعنا نلقي نظرة
الآن كما تعلم  يمكن للفيروسات بما في ذلك
فيروس كورونا أن تعيش على الأسطح
لعدة ساعات حتى عدة أيام
مما يعني أنه يتعين علينا التنظيف
طوال الوقت ونحصل أيضًا على الكثير من emai
أنا أقول انظر ، لقد نفدت هذه
المنظفات جيدًا ، والخبر السار هو أن
الصابون والماء هنا ليس فقط
بديلًا جيدًا ، يجادل العديد من العلماء
أنه في الواقع بديل أفضل
حصلت kali Thordarson على خيط Twitter رائع
حول هذا من Sidney
يذكرنا أن الفيروسات هي في الأساس مجرد
ثلاثة أشياء تتكون من بروتينات الحمض النووي الريبي (RNA)
والتي هي اللبنات
الأساسية وهذا الغلاف الدهني الذي يتضح
أن الصابون خاصة عندما تضعه على
أسطح مثل هذه يمكن أن يؤدي في الواقع إلى
تفتيت هذا الغلاف الدهني مما يتسبب في
الفيروس ليتم تدميره وبكل سهولة
د.  قال جون ويليامز من جامعة
بيتسبرغ إن الأمر أشبه
بالتفكير في كيفية تنظيف طبق زبداني ،
ربما لن تستخدم
الماء فقط ، ربما لن تستخدم
معقمًا كحوليًا ، لكن الصابون
والماء يؤديان المهمة ،
لذا فإن الصابون والماء فقط يؤديان المهمة.  لا تنسى المياه
الأسطح ذات اللمس العالي سواء مثل
هاتفك تأكد من تنظيف تلك التي
قد تستخدم الكثير من الصابون والماء في
ذلك وحتى أشياء مثل مفاتيح الإضاءة
ومقابض الأبواب ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي
تمنع بها نفسك من لمس الفيروس
لنفسك  والإصابة بالعدوى
آمل أن يساعد ذلك
[موسيقى]